vous n'êtes plus dit que les uns et les
autres à oui oui on a quand même un nom
bon bah écoutez dans 90 minutes enquêtes
sur tmc
on a fait la connaissance de christopher
christopher hill est absolument charmant
c'est pas vous en cluster non mais un
autre garde et qui dieu qui pour
affronter ces complexes pour dire voilà
j'ai envie de me sentir mieux me sentir
bien et partie justement faire du
naturisme s'accepter tel qu'il est
christopher s'attaque à un gros chantier
et surtout le jeune homme veut faire des
rencontres un exercice à risque pour les
hommes nus il a même envisagé le pire
tél l'érection sincèrement c'est une
question à chaque fois qu'ils tulle qui
me fait rire parce que je pense qu'on a
tellement peur au début dans la warwick
on n'a pas en tout cas
les vacances commencent bien en moins de
deux heures christopher mais parvenus à
assumer son corps en public
alors qu'est ce qu'on en pense qu'à
roanne mais elle elle me dit qu'elle
n'est pas pudique est-ce que vous avez
tout à fait des naturistes
moi j'étais à la limite du naturisme pas
soit la limite gare à la limite c'est
que je conçois toujours plus jolie
esthétiquement d'avoir un petit maillot
vous vous enlever le haut c'est ça le
dérange pas trop
la gare de l'autre ne vous gêne pas mais
rien et je le fais quand même dans un
périmètre assez restreint chez moi voilà
j'ai pas dans un camp naturiste à
d'accord mais en tout cas je me
sentirais comme un poisson dans l'eau si
j'avais dans un camp naturiste saml 2
rangerait pas du tout et le regard que
pourraient porter les autres sur vous ça
vous gêne pas non mais justement en fait
c'est là où on se trompe c'est qu'on
croit qu'on va regarder dans le détail
comment sont vos seins vos fesses etc
c'est pas c'est pas ça qui se passe en
fait au contraire ça désinhibe
complètement
on passe à autre chose directement et
moi je l'aï évaluer ce problème sésame
ou les drire élections lève sur il a
raison parce que qu'est ce qui reste
quand on est nu comme un ver des mois il
reste il reste la vérité voilà ce qu'on
est con à dire qu'on dégage l'énergie
coup vehicles voilà c'est ça c'est ça
qui est important au quai à la fin ils
achètent du saucisson est tellement fou
il regarde même pas sombrer aussi
regardent passer face à ça qui est
intéressant mais je trouve que c'est une
démarche qu'on devrait tous faire
d'accor et bien dans notre corps est
bien mais je le comprends a
effectivement d'être bien dans sa peau
et de volleyball dit nous le dit pas
dans la sphère personnelle dans la
sphère privée pourquoi pas bon après de
la halle et à la charcuterie aux as et
assure qu tri
à la poêle je sais pas je m'interrogeais
we go christophe parce que l'on vous
avez fait des expériences naturiste bien
sûr oui mais j'en fais non samedi bien
sûr sur la met dans des lieux dédiés
c'est à dire l'art est donc tentant des
clients comme ça ben non justement
pendant vingt ans la côte sauvage par
exemple avec la voyant voilà c'est donc
cet été de la fnaca faut me trouver
voilà et là y'a rien de plus plaisant
que nager à poil par exemple voilà après
de là à aller faire mes courses avec mon
appareil 3 pièces à l'air je suis pas
sûr chacun au rayon frais en plus est ce
que vous comprenez ce qu'ils disent
voilà on en plaisante mais ce qu'ils
disent c'est une philosophie de vie
c'est une façon d'appréhender la rame et
non sur la plage oui aux mains au
supermarché je vois pas l'intérêt voire
détonnant les lycéens qui ont raison
dire que vraiment dans le reportage là
on a vu qu'un petit extrait mais le
reportage est long et on comprend bien
que ce qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils
recherchent c'est là la sincérité
l'authenticité la simplicité et
effectivement quand on enlève tout bas
je vous assure valérie que il ressent
quasiment plus intéressant et plus vers
des naturistes se cache derrière les
choses et naturistes en fait autour de
la taxe si je n'ai pas du tout mais moi
je ne comprend pas le projet de ces
personnes je ne comprends pas vraiment
je n'arrive pas du tout à comprendre où
est ce qu'on peut trouver son plaisir à
se [ __ ] à poil
ce monsieur j'arrive et vous les îliens
et s'assumer et vous et moi qu'à me
dégoûte
je vous dis sincèrement ça me dégoûte et
qu'elle aurait vu ce même commencé dans
le chemin de quelqu'un avec est en train
d'aller faire ses courses comme ça à
poil tranquillement en train d'acheter
sa baguette qui goûte du saucisson qui
va acheter des moules des fritsch passé
mais moi je suis choqué je ne comprends
pas qu est ce que tu as peut honnêtement
que cela va lui changer de mettre un
maillot de bain ou juste un petit truc
au moins pour aller faire ses courses
d'accord c'est quand même particulier ça
vous gêne basse et vous ça vous gêne pas
alors
bonjour moi je tolère forcément tout à
fait la chose pour les femmes notamment
la question vous avez il avait une
petite appréhension de se dire peut-être
que si je crois ce qu'est une jeune
femme qui est plutôt avenante je risque
d'avoir des accidents de parcours
est ce que vous savez ça je pense pas
que ça puisse arriver parce qu'en effet
même l'homme préfère voir une femme sexy
voire trop sexy ça attise ça attire
l'attention beaucoup plus qu'une femme
totalement nue qui se balade est qu'à sa
baguette sous le bras
là pour le coup ça dakar est ça tue
l'amour un petit manque en fait pour
vous il ya aucune sexualité là dedans
c'est véritablement il vient il faut
appeler au calme et hypocrisie totale je
demandais ici à un homme si vous voulez
que je me déshabille je pense je suis
pas sûr que non mais franchement a même
pas dit non mais ce qu'on dit justement
que meyer abordables de qualité des
corps nus et non dans la tête de
certains hommes vous pouvez pas me dire
que quand ils voient 15 nanas à poil sur
la plage et pas du tout s'entend
l'émission avec car on sera tous nus
mais au passé
[Applaudissements]
j'ai toujours dit que je suis pas de
règles du genre naturiste etc mais mais
je pense effectivement comme comme le
dit christophe par exemple est tellement
de corps nus que ça ne soit devient
presque nord mais il ya trop de co2 il
n'y a pas de notion de désir puis c'est
un club familial et sont plus là où je
là où je me balade à pois non plus sur
la terre sauvage de la mer elle est un
peu froide donc je peux vous dire qu'il
n'ya pas de risque pour ces précisions à
la panique vraiment c'était nécessaire
toi ce sujet